hi I'm Evan Jones with Google cloud and
I'm really excited to have joy with us
here she is a data educator and a
supervisor at the Children's Hospital of
Philadelphia
welcome to the show joy thank you it's
great to be here yeah it's really
exciting a lot of things are happening
virtually these days and interviews are
just one of them but thankfully we both
have really good internet connections
and we've got a treasure trove of
questions to ask you particularly about
certification in your background do you
mind if we just jump in yeah fantastic
let's go all right tell me a little bit
about yourself and what brought you to
this certification and how it's related
to your work if you don't mind
sure so as you stated I work for the
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia and
we are a customer of Google cloud
platform as well as other cloud
providers and two years ago I was sent
to Google cloud next which was a great
opportunity and I really enjoyed it
and as part of the lead-up to the
conference I received an email inviting
me to consider apply for this diversity
cohort that was intended to help broaden
the appeal and broaden the class of
people who were certified as google
cloud experts and that was something
that really appealed to me and it
appealed to me because number one for my
own professional growth and education I
thought that would be very useful for me
absolutely yeah as well as the fact that
I am a data educator and it's really
important to me to multiply everything
that I'm able to do and teach others and
deputize them in turn to train still
others so it just seemed like it was a
real opportunity to in my local
community at chop the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia and beyond to
really grow some education around cloud
computing what would you say to those
folks who hear the word examination or
certificate and they might not have a
strong background in data or have the
technical skills but they look at you
and they say you know she can do it I
can do it let's go do this thing I'm
gonna sign up I'm gonna be the next that
next code
or that that's coming out Joey what
would you say to those people who have a
little bit of at Google we call it
impostor syndrome which is you walk into
a room and you feel like everyone else
in the room is you know smarter than you
as done all this and they deserve to be
here and you might not you feel like you
don't belong there
even though absolutely with with
everything of their core being they need
to be there and they should be there how
would you motivate those people that are
going to be joining that next cohort
after you what would you say to them
well I have two soundbites one is don't
believe everything you think so so just
because you think this is beyond your
skills or you know you're you're too far
behind because you're over 50 or you
never worked with computers or whatever
the reason is don't don't believe
everything you think and also if you're
the smartest person in the room you are
in the wrong room I love that one you
need to be with people that are smarter
than you and know more than you and
start being comfortable with being
uncomfortable I think that's something
in this current this is being filmed
during the code 19 pandemic and a lot of
us are getting comfortable with being
uncomfortable and that's a real life
lesson so I will say that impostor
syndrome I don't think ever really goes
away but I have learned to talk back to
it
and one of the things that I I find
because I've taught technology to
children and adults and one of the
things that I've noticed is the
emergence of the confidence gap and in
my experience this happens around fifth
or sixth grade where some people
predominantly boys although not
exclusively feel very confident in math
and science and when they run across
challenges like a really hard math
problem math starts getting really hard
around six seventh grade right when they
run across a hard math problem they
think to themselves wow this is a hard
problem
I am super-smart for tackling this hard
problem and then there's a group of
students predominantly but not
exclusively girls who maybe because
they've done well in
school up to this point without as much
effort realize that well this is much
more effort than I'm accustomed to I
must not be up to the task and in that
confidence gap I still continue to see
in people and it's interesting to me
because I work with very very smart
people I work with people who are MD
PhDs I work with students who were in
grad school at yeshiva who are adult
learners who have important full-time
jobs I work with very smart people and
they have impostor syndrome and they
feel like wow this is hard and I wrote
some code and it failed and what they
don't realize because they're not in
this industry is in tech you fail all
the time you fail and you fail and you
fail and you finally succeed but you
don't get to rest in it and roll around
and how wonderful it is because you've
got to go on to the next thing and start
failing again and that's not like most
jobs so I do a lot of soft skills and
helping people get comfortable with
failure and get comfortable with not
being great at things you're not gonna
be great at this when you start and
that's fine you're not supposed to be
great so hang in there you're gonna be
fine don't panic when you make a mistake
and don't believe everything you think I
think that's that's perfect joy I love
the get comfortable being uncomfortable
even to this day I mean a lot of people
look at the folks who work at Google and
oh you know you've got a job at Google
that's like you know everyone there is
you know genius and writing the next
self-driving car application or
something like that I can't I can't tell
you you know I can I can tell you every
day there's a moment where I'm like
you're running into that that same type
of wall that same type of wall where
you're in fifth grade or sixth grade and
you're up against a math problem or a
technical problem or an interpersonal
problem and you feel you feel that a
little bit of that uncomfortability and
I could I couldn't plus one or agree
with your point more of its the step
that you take next it's either you're
gonna run away from that you're gonna
say it's all right to feel uncomfortable
but I'm still gonna do this anyways I
think that that's a perfect message out
there all right uh this certification I
would love to ask you for more questions
than that if you don't mind how how is
the
certification itself either impacted the
the organization you work for or the
communities that you're you're a part of
sure I mean especially as an adjunct
professor it's very important to me that
the education that I'm giving my
students is the most cutting edge
because it might take them two three
four years these are adult learners who
are very busy to finish their master's
degree which means that by the time they
leave what I taught them their first
year is already a couple of days a
couple of years out of date right so I
want to make sure that at the the day I
deliver that lecture or share that
collab notebook that it is the most
up-to-date I can possibly do and so I do
a lot of advocating with senior folks at
my educational institution at Yeshiva
University for adopting cloud platforms
and saying this is where our students
are going to be working so you know it's
sure they should certainly install
Python on their laptops absolutely you
know if you want to have you know a
sequel server spun up someplace you know
on campus that's great too but
realistically as far as job skills our
students are going to be working in the
cloud so how can we really leverage my
skills and whatever topic I'm teaching
whether that's learning to program in
Python or doing computer vision or you
know some sort of data engineering or
data pipelines no matter what sort of
topic I'm teaching there's a way to tie
it to cloud in a way that really is
building students abilities to
understand the vocabulary to be able to
be autodidact right to have the
terminology to know the concepts well
enough to know what to search for you
know I I always say that so much of what
I teach is telling people what to go
goal and absolutely
how did Google write you know my and I
and I also tell people you know what I
Google this every day too so if you
think that I have the syntax memorized I
do not people always get surprised
I do a lot of bigquery and sequel
courses and they always get surprised
from presenting in the classroom and I'm
going to Google date to look up like
some of these functions they're like
wait a minute
you know you presented on you know an
online platform this with ease and I'm
like I don't memorize this stuff but I
know where to look absolutely couldn't
agree more
yeah so I mean that's that's my life as
an adjunct professor I I would also say
I've had people come to me at work or
just in the community and say hey I saw
in LinkedIn that you were Google cloud
certified I want to find out more about
this and these are often career changers
or people who discovered to their
surprise that they really liked DevOps
or platform engineering or some of the
background engineering and maybe that
wasn't the job that they were hired for
but they've realized that well you know
I have some technical skills and
abilities that I didn't know about and
in fact I had a conversation with
someone who has a lot of information
science experience but it's not a
programmer she would not consider
herself a programmer and she said can I
pursue this I said absolutely right you
know there are there are specialty
professional grade exams for
applications developers but you know
this initial associate level exam it's
just a great overview of lots of
different things and I said if nothing
else what it will do is give you a
chance to learn a lot figure out what
parts you like and what parts you don't
for example I am so grateful that there
are network engineers I thank my lucky
stars for them every day because I could
not do their job right I feel but I feel
the same way and any questions that I
ever get on like IP addresses and
routing like private network traffic I'm
like I mean I look up how do you write a
site or block notation every time every
time the next once a quarter
you know sometimes it'll stick around
for a little while so one of the things
you know I have had a very circuitous
career path and along the way I took ten
years
ten years out of technology to do
full-time volunteer work and so I worked
in prisons and schools and homeless
shelters in Spain and Bolivia and El
Salvador and one of the things that I
really fell in love with was the power
of Education to change people's lives at
every level right I worked with women
who spoke only their indigenous language
did not speak Spanish maybe they only
spoke to our Amata in Bolivia and and
realizing that just their inability to
speak Spanish kept them out of the
marketplace it kept them impoverished it
kept them under the control sometimes of
domestic abusers and all the way up to
people that I saw in prison who were
getting degrees and making their lives
better and so I really you know I've
I've come back to full-time work because
I love technology and I love education
and I'm lucky enough to combine the two
and at the end of the day what I would
love to do is go back into some of these
lower resource areas and say hey NGOs I
would like to help you boost your signal
let's take a look at your data how can
you be in charge of your data story how
can I help you there are resources that
I can connect you with and not only can
I help you in Geo but can I can I also
help the community you serve what's the
population you serve what are they like
because the wonderful thing about
technology is it's not the formal
degrees you have it's what you can do
and this is one of the few industries I
feel like that that is that continues to
be true for and knowing that I have the
skills in Google cloud platform to help
other people at all levels including
people with very low literacy computer
literacy that they can access this stuff
through a URL they need a strong
internet connection which it's not
nothing that can be challenging but with
just a strong internet connection
and a Chromebook or a low powered laptop
I can really help someone grow in skills
that will help them make a living help
them provide for their families and also
improve the lot of organizations in
under-resourced areas that are doing
really important good things that's
that's so well I love that dream and
it's the dream of Google as a whole
their core mission is to make the
world's information universally
accessible to anyone and everyone you
know not just people in the United
States not just people of a certain
class or a certain privilege as well so
it just it reminds me when you speak
like the Chromebook in a URL in the
Internet and they access one of your
ipython notebooks and they're doing a
machine learning model that would have
previously taken an entire Google data
center to do like 10 years ago now
they're running on their laptop in a
cafe or something like that - it's just
it's being able to access that
technology into your point being able to
access the educational resources and
those badges like the certifications as
well it's just such a powerful story joy
it's like thank you so much for sharing
not only your background but just the
clear passion I thought I'm a passionate
person i listening to you just gets me
motivated to take even more of these
certifications as well I certainly don't
have them all so thank you so much so so
much any closing words from your side to
inspire these the Watchers I put you in
the spot no I'll say mine in that and
then and then we can we can close with
yours so mine at Google we have a
moniker and it's is from different than
other companies that I work with is good
artists copy but great artists steal so
one of my favorite things that you
mentioned is these collaborative
notebooks for machine learning a lot of
our courses that I put out I draw
inspiration from a lot of the other
works that are out there the data
science in particular is meant to be a
community of folks kind of achieving a
goal or an objective together so don't
feel like you need to go it alone
especially if you're looking at other
people's resources as well and certainly
internally at Google we're constantly
stealing each other's work and making
the insights together as well so all
right closes with the pithy a pithy
no person you know so I come at this
from a data scientist perspective so
other people may come to GCP from a lot
of interest in high-performance
computing or you know sort of networked
resilience or other issues or areas of
interest but I'm principally a data
scientist so I'm gonna give you the
answer of a data scientist if you want
to learn how to be a data scientist
because you think this is interesting
then you definitely need to be involved
with Google cloud platform because one
of the best ways to learn data is using
big data and there is a great set of
resources for you in Google public data
sets and bigquery which is just a great
place to get started you can
there's tons of tutorials that will help
you there that are available at no cost
the hosting of the data sets is at no
cost and all the work that you need to
do can be done in free tier so there are
lots of ways that even without
participating in a formal training
process or signing up for your an exam
that you can grow your skills and really
find a dataset that you're passionate
about I tell people if you love sports
look at sports data if you're concerned
about hunger and poverty look for those
datasets find something you care about
and you will definitely find some trends
that make you scratch your head or make
you angry or make you excited or make
you ask questions so find some data work
with it and change the world I love I
love it that's such a great way to close
all right we have joy with us from chop
which is the Children's Hospital of
Philadelphia thank you so much for
taking this time to talk a little bit
about it too dei and your entire
background that's led you this far and
carrying forward with you for your
students and adults that you're taking
forward as well thank you so much thank
you so much for your time as well this
is great
be well